Oh Batman about me over welcome the fat
man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I am ma
Bernard and you hear that lack of crowd
nobody cheering our entry like Christ
entering Jerusalem on an ass
that's because we're not at our home at
the scum and villainy Cantina where my
home yes
me and Mark sitting here doing a home
show the fat King couple homeboys what
up you know I'm heading off soon to New
Orleans to start Jay and Silent Bob
reboot so it'll be a minute before we do
stuff unless we get this show going down
in New Orleans which is absolutely
possible you're looking into it once I
get down there so before you know I went
off for [ __ ] a few months we figured
we'd get together one last time and just
[ __ ] do it the way we used to do it
in this room ain't no school like the
old school it's been it's been a busy
couple of weeks man since the last show
we did I was at the 22nd of January and
now it's the 9th of February it's been a
[ __ ] ton of meetings man I was gainfully
unemployed for a stretch and now I am
NOT gainfully unemployed I am now
gainfully employed Mark's got a job I
got a job I can't I can't save a job and
it's one of those jobs that has a time
limit on it yeah like it it's it's a all
these job seen bad they do it's all
[ __ ] freelance you're stitching
together freelance gigs and and they're
all weak terms so this is a 20-week job
which could extend further than that
could be less than that if it doesn't
work out but when you're a flash or
Supergirl right like Eric Roscoe mm-hmm
is he on 20-week or no he's just annual
so he's on an all episodes produced deal
given
where he is on the pay scale in the
latter so which means that if they're
doing 25 episodes of flash in a given
year
it takes according to the guild 2.4
weeks per episode they have to pay you
every two point four weeks for whatever
you get per episode all right yep
whether you have written that episode or
not correct
Wow that's not yeah and that's why
people want to be in this business I
guess
totally so like Erik will work probably
for about 48 weeks a year on the flash
and get like four weeks off sorry so uh
how long for four weeks maybe three
weeks oh you're not wrong cuz I remember
like at one point like they finish in
March or April but they [ __ ] go back
to work well I like mains you yeah it's
like gonna be fast [ __ ] turnaround
there suddenly back at if telling a
whole new long different narrative yeah
like that's that that was how TV writing
used to be when it was just network
stuff when it was hey every show goes
for 24 episodes every show starts in
premieres in September and ends in out
of June but um when we take the summer
off you take some review reruns to do
reruns you go travel go on hiatus maybe
do a movie if you're an actor who broke
the rerun who was the first network to
go you know what original summer
programming um I think [ __ ] I mean I
think it started with reality it start
with [ __ ] like Survivor no further back
tell me a television show called Beverly
Hills 902 Vox I started producing summer
program breaking the paradigm and they
were especially using the kids remember
the host oh no no no - and I like Fox
cool we can we've to help these kids in
Beverly Hills they go to the beach every
[ __ ] day if the show set the summer
and why are we not making episodes in
the summer it's just stupid and I
remember that was as revolutionary as
like you know mr. Gorbachev tear down
this wall
I remember when it happened I was like
are you [ __ ] me like why isn't
anyone ever done this before like make
new I don't even watch 9:02 no but I'm
right now because I said how smart like
no one else is working they're working
they're gonna lead the ratings by
default [ __ ] and then now we live in a
world where there are no seasons like
programming never [ __ ] stops like
Network still do twenty or two or
whatever fun but it's not like then we
every we all take off for the summer
like then the network start their summer
programming their little summer berg do
you think that's uh that's part of what
led to like American obesity which was
it used to be hey kids go out and play
there's nothing on TV anyway go [ __ ]
kick a rock go ride a bike go play some
ball
but wait 90210 is on mannequins I can
watch Brenda all summer long
this is [ __ ] man let's watch them
live a life look how pretty they are
yeah man it's a different yeah and so
now like most TV is ten thirteen
episodes long most of it is on its own
[ __ ] schedule like you know if it's
streaming it doesn't matter what it's on
because there's no advertising they're
worrying about even if it's Network even
if it's FX or Comedy Central or [ __ ]
whatever else it's alright we can do
this whenever we want to whatever you
want to it's weird we've seen a change
in our lifetimes I mean if my old man
was alive I'm sure my old man would be
like you think it's [ __ ] weird what
you've seen in your lifetime there was
no television when I was born
[ __ ] like I remember when they
were like look here's a TV and we were
like what but yeah it's in my house and
then if he made it like cuz my mom was
alive she went there for the first TV or
anything but like she's seen more [ __ ]
than me and I feel like I've seen it all
I'm like I was there when the [ __ ]
microwave was invented mmm I was there
when they introduced [ __ ] cable
television and then the DVD player with
the VHS and then on the Betamax then the
DVD player like and it just it changed
so [ __ ] fast
like in my grandfather's lifetime he was
like I remember the horse and then the
car and the TV and then I died so many
more [ __ ] thing maybe he had some
Wars in there yeah every 20 years it was
a giant [ __ ] thing that kicked the
world on its axis now he's every [ __ ]
10 minutes yeah somebody's like here's a
phone you could fold up sticking your
[ __ ] on it work but call me call me a
lot hold on Monday first day two days
from now let's hear it for the working
man yeah I mean that's the weird thing
about TV man is that like you interview
for a job on like a Wednesday and then
you hear on like Thursday could you let
go work on Monday so you'll walk into
that room it's like a first day it's
cool that always is like hey are you
guys hey don't you do that podcast be
careful right like the we do a show is I
face this all the time of money we do a
show where we tend to talk about other
people's stuff one of us is generally
positive you may come into contact with
the people that make bizarre yeah that
he's going to feed on the other one of
us is Mark it's like let me tell you the
14 things I didn't like about iron fist
stumble into rooms like oh you ran iron
fist oh man it was in color in every
that's awesome man for the guy that came
out here you know left George Brown and
left [ __ ] you know working for
legitimate organizations you know and
like
solid [ __ ] secure gigs too like
[ __ ] you know whether they calls
float your own boats [ __ ] set your
own style whatever [ __ ] hang your own
shingle
yeah if out here dad so far so good man
right like banging job bang job
yeah you know and it seems the the more
I get to do with the less time it is
between jobs
you know like Castle Rock was awesome
and then it took nine months between
Castle Rock and Treadstone and then
tread shown was awesome and then it took
about six weeks yeah about six weeks
between that and the new thing which I
can't talk about exactly what it is
until a nice start he's got another
[ __ ] sweet gig so do you think I mean
it's gotta be now you know you've been
in it from like work breeds work right
it does it does that simple it's like
now they can trust you because like
always worked on [ __ ] this this okay
that Castle Rock can be nominated for
[ __ ] cool alright this is what he got
for the last thing he's gonna one more
for this one alright no problem we can
start to negotiate up and you get your
quote and your titles get better and but
it is it's momentum it's being able to
like this thing and then this thing and
it feels like there's a there's a hill
you're rolling down and you beginning to
sweep [ __ ] up as you go and not going
wood man but yeah this is this is what
the dream how long before you [ __ ]
they're standing there and you're like I
like to thank the Academy the Academy of
auto-painting doing a great job I'm like
thank the Academy bus I'm looking
forward to that since our last show I
think I went to Sundance and interviewed
all my cinematic betters should travel
there's anything relevant to our world
that happened there now how long you
been going to Sundance like irregularly
well this was my 25th well I don't know
it's not like my 25th year I've been
25 years but 25 years ago Clark's
happened rent so this year at Sundance
it was like 25 years since the moment
for since first time I went to Sundance
but I would say at this point of the 25
I feel like it's now 14 or 15 that I
have gone for one reason or another
sometimes I've been a film there the
last four years I've been interviewing
people for four IMDB one time I was a
judge other times I've won up for other
people's movies and stuff so yeah I've
got some time there I feel like a
Sundance Kid like like this is the first
year I was like oh it makes sense to
have me interview people appear like
IMDB is smart to do this because I
started my career you know it took me
three [ __ ] years to understand like
oh yeah if I have an identity thing with
something I spilled some blood in this
mud yeah I think John fish and my friend
sold Clark's bag today with the
wonderful independent cinema tomes like
mic slackers and eggs I was texting with
him you know he's his imprint an indie
film is deeper and goes back for the
money sold she's got to have it he sold
Roger and me
parting glances like [ __ ] very big
movies working girls like you his is any
credibility is beyond reproach
and then we a slacker he sold that and
then later on he sold clerks and stuff
so I was texting with him Oz up there
and looked like 25 years man like 25
years ago you were up here and we were
up here we go
and he texted back me laughs he goes we
built this city it is like what sorry
who built what happened this is his last
one right didn't he I am me I'm sure
he'll you know pop I don't know I mean
look I don't know I can't say I'm sure
anything but like you know
this is the year were in the beginning
thing he was like look this place is
fine without me so here's the kids and
turned it over them very quickly I think
he still did the director brunch maybe
he'll still continue doing that mmm but
you know he's I guess his thing is like
this thing doesn't need me anymore right
and it's in great hands and so you know
when he's in his 80s right and say like
you know I'm not it's not like he's
slowing down but he's like I guess you
put your limited down that dog you put
your limited energy at whatever age into
where it's needed and Sundance it's not
like hey man can you go out there and
drum up some attention for the Sundance
Film Festival and nobody's gonna come
unless you're here his creation is you
know and it wasn't his flat-out creation
the US Film Festival existed prior to it
becoming the Sundance Film Festival but
Robert Redford came in gave it an
identity brought attention to it and
stuff and turned it into what it is
today and you know it's now far bigger
than him there are people that go to
Sundance that don't know who Robert
Redford is you know no sense some young
cats who were just like whoo it though
was he in the Civil War the literal
Civil War no it was real all won money
hey guys real old was it captain america
civil war zone
the Winter Soldier was he winter
soldiers yeah yeah that's right because
he was the one [ __ ] programming
amateur yeah man it's just it's it's
crazy I've spent enough time up there
were like like I'm a fixture now and
it's nice no it's nice to have that like
it I love longevity I it means I'm still
doing it B it means it worked on some
level but you know it was it I don't
know it's you get to meet with all sorts
of cats when you're interviewing them
and stuff and like I just get to see
everybody's expression
change when they come into the room you
know usually I'm getting people that
have been interviewed at [ __ ] a bunch
of places or that's where the first stop
before their long day begins and so you
get a chance to impress on a bunch
different levels number one they come in
and there's this like Oh what what are
you doing and this kind of like is this
how bad you're so there's a bit of
there's a bit of that and and there's
also the sense of relief you get from
them or they're like oh well he knows
how [ __ ] dreadful this process could
be so maybe he won't ask us the same
[ __ ] boring [ __ ] and I don't I
try to go about it my own way and so you
know then you get a chance to like try
to impress people and it's so [ __ ]
strange mark like like the [ __ ] that
like turns my crank
that I never knew it would we did an
interview with like alfre woodard was in
this movie that one the director won the
Best Director she plays a warden I want
to say the movies called the warden but
it's not that but she plays a warden who
like you know deals of people on death
row and she strikes up a friendship with
a guy on death row who may or may not
have done it his heading toward capital
punishment is about to lose his last
appeal or whatever the [ __ ] so when I
heard about it I'm like oh my god is
[ __ ] up like number one when I
interviewed her I was just like there's
no way you don't win an award at least a
nomination like everybody loves you and
here you would you're playing a role
that's like the fitting of your [ __ ]
magnificent Talent so at the richard
schiff was in the movie as well and you
know he's in [ __ ] west wing against
many other things but i just met him
that day for the first time and so at
the end of the interview like we gave
them they they were so
and happy with the interview like they
were like at the end of the festival we
heard like we they you know they're
still talking about you you you were
their favorite interview and so but
Richard Schiff was like you fun to talk
to and then like I interview I like kept
we kept engaged and stuff but then after
he like he left like the you know Susan
the Booker she's alone the books all the
talent for the interviews she came in
she's like just want to tell you the
Richard Schiff said he loves you and
that was as a favor interview he's done
up here and the amount of perverse
almost orgasmic pleasure that I took in
hearing like Richard Schiff was really
happy with that interview he was like oh
my god like I did it I earned a new fan
it's crazy how that's like honestly why
I do it like they they pay me to be
there don't get me wrong but I don't see
that money so I know everything they
don't just give you stacks of it when
you're done no it's some check that goes
to my accountant so for all I know for
all I know like it don't even exist
right all I get out of it is like
Richard Schiff really likes you and now
it's the weirdest people like Lorena
gallo
the former Lorena Bobbitt mmm
interviewed her for Jordan Peele has a
four-part amazon miniseries 6:4 called
Lorena about the story for hours on that
story because it's [ __ ] fascinating
and when she came to be interviewed man
like a whole [ __ ] day I was like oh
my god I'm the worst guy for this like
honestly like you can't I'm like dick
and fart joke don't like I can't like
it's just this isn't a [ __ ] disaster
in the making no no no you're [ __ ]
good at this and you're you'll get it
sat down interviewer and you know it was
[ __ ] so fascinating and so real and
she was like wonderful but like it
occurs to me and she's sitting there
challenged her and the filmmaker was New
Jersey
kid who like come out to Los Angeles and
like one day he was when I he came in to
be interviewed as I came down I'm Kevin
he was just like we met before I was
like get out of your where he was like
when I first moved out to California I
went to eat at the islands burger place
and instantly I was like oh my god I
remember this kid and he was like you
were there and I said hi and I told you
I just moved out and I was like please
tell me I was in a deck he was like you
were really really wonderful and stuff
like that I'm like lucky you [ __ ]
like you've got this many series is
enough so as she tells the story you
know of the it's the story of course we
know about John Wayne violin [ __ ] but
like this is the perspective I never
thought about it through her and the
filmmaker are talking about this this is
a woman who wasn't from this country
comes to this country ghek marries you
know in a [ __ ] abusive you know
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] country fails are
there ghosts to the court system like
hey please get this to stop country fell
dude dude does what he [ __ ] raped her
essentially and so she [ __ ] like cuts
his dick off then she gets put through
the justice system country fails are
there then the American media turned it
into this like [ __ ] like she gotta
[ __ ] a deck off like media sensations
created the 24-hour news cycle created
one maybe not created that kind of
existed but fed the 24-hour news cycle
created like cameras in the courtroom
court TV which is now truTV there they
doubled tripled their ratings here in
the whole like Lorena Bobbitt thing like
you know I asked her at one point I was
like this [ __ ] country like failed
you over and over again like I can't
believe you stayed like I would have
[ __ ] laughed and stuff
it's really sad so anyway talking to her
man like she was just absolutely [ __ ]
wonderful and you know at the end of the
interview somebody was like crying oh
really
like you and I was like I had no idea
how much I craved the [ __ ] not just
acceptance but like you know props yeah
the validation of like I'm good at this
or not even that but just like yeah I
guess I cuz it's not even I'm good at
this it's more like oh they like me they
really like I got that Sally Field
[ __ ] thing where I'm like always
[ __ ] shocked that people go for me
and stuff like that but but I boy I got
to meet some fascinating cats and she
was like she might have been the
discovery of all mmm
Sundance for me I was like wow man like
who knew like to me you were just a name
and the press and a face that I would
see on TV and you rarely if ever heard
her voice and stuff so it took her a few
years but she gets to use her voice now
I've had many serious looks fantastic
Jordan Peele just killing it yeah like
like oh I I can do this I'll do this I
can do this
I'll do this I'll do this and the
filmmaker told me a story about like you
know he met Jordan and baikin they would
go to lunch every [ __ ] once in a
while and stuff like that and tell each
other what they were gonna and he told
him that he was like working on this
lorina thing and he was just like I my
god I want to try to make that happen
and then when get out happen Jordan like
stuck to it and he was just like let's
go set that up if I can set it up pants
on something you know what I'm saying
like using his powers for good not just
like I'm gonna satisfy myself but like
turning out good work yeah
and it feels you know and I I I am
sympathetic to this feeling of the I've
been working for a long time to get here
yeah and now that I'm here it's a sprint
not a marathon yeah all those do all the
things that I can do because I don't
know how much longer it's gonna last I
don't know how much longer they're gonna
answer my [ __ ] phone calls right so
here's all of the [ __ ] that I love I'm
gonna do my best to make it all happen
smart yeah I interviewed him back when I
was a Playboy for some like [ __ ]
like ten minute thing with some Super
Bowl party that Samsung threw like
Jordan Peele is gonna be here do you
want to interview them they're asking me
you know that we have this thing called
a lucky
seven wishes seven questions we asked
celebrities and it was like when was the
[ __ ] funniest movie ever stars like
this [ __ ] rubric then we could just
spin out over and over everything I
asked my questions means that yeah
anything else I'm like I don't know
[ __ ] dude I thought your time was
done it's like nah man I tell you what
I'm gonna give you some news my managers
not gonna want me to tell you this but
I'm making a horror movie I was like
really yeah it's called get out I'm like
ooh like after that Eddie Murphy sketch
where he's like hey man this house is
really beautiful and he goes yeah
and look the chandeliers lovely and I'm
like yeah and then the ghost says oh is
it get out time to go yeah we gotta go
yeah we gotta go
too bad they say it was very summer um
but I think that's that's all time yeah
I saw the poster for the first that we
rift on that whole [ __ ] bed is again
McGinnis movie it's all about kind of
race and horror and how they intersect
it's like that's that's that's for you
go ahead take that like exclusive Jordan
P let's make it a horror movie called
get out the one time I ever broke news
is because Jordan was like this was a
fun interview I'm gonna give you
something but yeah like I don't
interview a lot of people I didn't even
when I was a journalist but when I did I
only got real pleasure one second I've
never been asked that question before
all right hey this was cool all right
now let's keep talking I get in with
Christopher Nolan ones and interview him
for The Hollywood Reporter just before
just after Dark Knight Rises came out
and I met him in New York and this
[ __ ] fancy ass hotel and he said to
his publicist thing was BB Lerner at the
time and somebody like that and it was
like all right Chris if you need
anything just let me know I'll come back
and check on you
all right thanks very much and she walks
away he started talking for like 20
minutes
and she comes over and she's like Dini
do you think so I got like some more tea
and she walks away we talk to another 20
minutes and she comes back again
it's like Dean anything Chris I'd like
some more tea which apparently was a
signal for if I didn't want any more tea
the interview is over and if he kept
asking for tea we could keep on talking
right and it's funny it's classy yeah
and so like we talked for like an hour
and a half or so and left and I get this
call from her in the next couple days
it's like do you
enough because chris is happy to get
back on the phone and talk to you if you
don't have what you need it's like no I
think I got it cuz he was a little
concern you a little bit all over the
place I was like yeah I was just curious
about [ __ ] and like I had my questions I
want to ask but then I was like so is
Gotham City alive for you like is that a
character that you're trying to build
because it's different every movie and
make it bigger in every movie actually
it is yeah it's just like I triggered
some [ __ ] that he gets to say that he's
never got to say before but clearly has
some thoughts on yeah just you know
there isn't an ornament of pleasure of
the asking question so my husband asked
before and doing an interview that
they're like you know what I was [ __ ]
fun it's also the aspect of just like he
may not [ __ ] be a big fan of everybody
that comes through but like you are more
likely a fan of like a little piece of
their [ __ ] career or you know in some
cases lots of it and blah blah blah
where you can blow them up for [ __ ] be
like a how [ __ ] or just people where
you're like wow I never met you and like
you're a big part of my [ __ ] life
growing up because I got seen you in is
it to me more I don't think I've ever
met her in real life I think maybe I saw
her at the Charlie's Angel 2 premiere
like years ago but like I interview her
up interviewed her at Sundance and like
is [ __ ] up cuz as I'm sitting there
talking to her
number one like she must have [ __ ]
painting that looks like ancient and
withered some mansion behind a locked
door because she like she I'm you know
she she may not look like blame it on
Rio when she was like I don't know 2019
but she still [ __ ] looks like you
know let's make pottery and I'll cry
Demi Moore like I haven't said two hours
like you [ __ ] you're so good at your
job you made a [ __ ] bolt cut work in
a movie once pen like she just like she
like I'm she's far
amber hmm but as you sat there and talk
to her like it's crazy I'm like oh my
god you've been in so many like
everybody got a favorite to me more move
you been in so many [ __ ] movies and
[ __ ] and so many massive [ __ ] flicks
you know it it was weird
liking and then at the end of the
interview I was like because it wasn't
on camera as I came in there's one you
and I have one thing in common we both
survived all right well let's talk about
our betters I'm sure there's something
interesting going on in the world of
[ __ ] news and Mark has a nose for
news so we dug up some news we can use
right here man so what do we got what we
talking about well it since the last we
spoke
they're so weird no Q&A after this I
know I mean you asked me a question was
white panther how do you feel about
Batman being black there's a lot of that
in the news last week I tweet I texted
mark to be like then we cover this I
believe we're the authorities on that we
walk down there certainly I was getting
hit on Twitter like what do you think
about this because I'm apparently the
guy who talks about Batman
wee-doggie go it was weirdest a pop-up
on Twitter subject where like I don't
know who somebody suggested but they're
like you know what if it was [ __ ]
Michael B Jordan I'm like I don't know
we've been saying like what about it
yourself before the last two three years
I love it well yeah it it did kind of
hit the news and it's so strange because
I maybe I'm spoiled because like we do
the show and the next week there's
always I got no [ __ ] ten articles
about some [ __ ] that we talked about
including like bugging Kevin Smith
thinks this movie would make a billion
dollars if I hated Kevin Smith and
believe me sometimes I do that would I
would
that would make me hate him so much more
that would make my [ __ ] iron burn if
I saw the headline Kevin Smith thinks
Batman Beyond movie with Michael Keith
would make a billion dollars a bill good
[ __ ] Pierre's [ __ ] if he thinks that
he never made a movie worth a [ __ ] so
there's another thing - uh-oh Tom Cruise
as because we would make a billion does
again if you're the Angie Kemper Z like
why is Tom Cruise gonna be Wolverine no
then why am I get it I'm with you [ __ ]
Kevin Smith but he talked about that
[ __ ] that being said we do talk about
things that wind up as new stories quite
a bit this was the one that I was
irritated where I'm like hey we've
talked about over on fat man Beyond
let's all go to the videotape yeah holy
[ __ ] but yeah that spurred by the first
news item which is Affleck is not coming
back as Batman which we kind of knew
what everybody yeah everybody I mean we
knew without confirmation but that was
this going back to Justice League right
yeah they was people were like the word
is you might not return it yeah he
didn't seem I want to get in shape for
this one so it's so weird that you say
that because like you said I want to be
fun then I looked at the movie the next
time and I was like oh yeah you know in
the one and believe me I ain't talking
it's not like hey man I know you're
getting [ __ ] shape and [ __ ] I had to
die to even [ __ ] think about losing
weight but in Batman V Superman there is
that like [ __ ] oh yeah spit shirt off
training scene and then Justice League
not too much no and you know maybe
that's cuz they got characters and stuff
screen but there was a whole scene where
he's like with Wonder Woman and he's
like he'd been dislocated his shoulder
and could have taken off that would have
been the scene
meanwhile Momoa is like hey I'm just I'm
just gonna rip my shirt off and dive
into the ocean
ie not movie crossed a billion it did
just kept going I saw something with her
like Aquaman coming a home video and I
was like really already it does can't
[ __ ] ring a few more bucks out of
that but I guess they don't need to they
[ __ ] destroy it at the box of his
billion dollars DC Universe is on a
track now like you know uh track it
wasn't before but like now you can see
they're like I we got one we got one
they got to was Wonder Woman back him
back they got Wonder Woman and [ __ ]
Aquaman so I could see like them putting
away two big toys for a little bit and
concentrating on the more interesting IP
that they haven't test-driven before
these avi we saw a trailer for birds of
prey or what is that what they're
calling it Gotham down yeah birds no
birds of prey there's you know a [ __ ]
teaser from like day one a shooting it's
like a makeup test I think it's what
they're doing so you know look get put
in the costume do your makeup who's
gonna shoot you for a while and stitch
it together with music but you know what
I'll tell you again
you know I got a glance at [ __ ] what's
gonna go on and [ __ ] and you know I was
a guy at this [ __ ] movies real so now
it feels like though like let's do some
[ __ ] with some [ __ ] that we've never
done some [ __ ] with before it seems to
be working out yeah I mean it it feels
I'm not gonna say it feels like taking a
fistful of darts and throwing it at a
board and hoping that things stick
whether you want them to stick but it
seems like the plan is to not have a
plan the plan is to respond to hey we
really excited about the Shazam things I
gonna mesh with this other [ __ ]
not really alright go ahead do it we're
excited about a joker movie does that
measure this other [ __ ] no not so much
alright do it it's cool do it as long as
people keep giving them that we roll
what we're gonna do but uh but you know
Affleck no Affleck Reeves has made it
clear yeah they dated the movie for 2021
and and yes Affleck will not be
returning as the Dark Knight uh he's
made it clear it's more noirish yeah
sort of Detective tech the leans into
detective which again we had talked
about like a year against
um it's probably not but that's what I
want to see I mean come on make it
[ __ ] fifty million dollar Batman
movie takes place in a set like you know
and it's an old [ __ ] Victorian
mansion in each room has some horrible
[ __ ] freak show in it that like he's
got a face like it's you get to meet his
entire [ __ ] rogues gallery can you
imagine how easy that would be to cast
mm-hmm
like hey man we need you for two days
like one day is travel because like what
it's like yeah man he's meeting a buncha
you could be Tweedledee [ __ ] this
[ __ ] playing you know Clayface this
[ __ ] doing the one seen as as misters
eyes like oh my god you know what mark I
make a billion dollars a billion dollars
that would definitely make me [ __ ]
half half a billion dollar if you get
like hey listen we need a we need a
two-face we know Harvey Dent Clooney you
want to come back just just play ball
with us for like three days moved
you said Clooney you come back to the
base all of that made blood rush to my
[ __ ] dick could you imagine like he's
like yeah man like believe me I don't I
don't want to be Batman again but
[ __ ] I would crush two-face
although you know he could totally he
staged Kim another role of Batman it
wasn't his fault
yeah he got a Schumacher Batman
Commissioner going yeah yeah or or you
know flashpoint mmm
did you imagine if they used him as
Thomas Wayne there so he got to clay
Batman and redeemed
like Batman not a he did anything wrong
but like [ __ ] like I get to play it
cool Batman yeah but he don't need it he
just made a billion dollars on [ __ ]
booze right would you my god Kim Qasim
ego skater the set which is gonna drink
tequila all [ __ ] day that's that's an
artist who can now beat afford to be
choosy yeah I remember hearing somewhere
and I cannot confirm it and if this is
an urban legend I just happened to like
it but the reason he did those Nescafe
[ __ ] coffee ads it's because he has a
satellite that he keeps in the air over
like
Darfur to make sure that there's no
genocides happening and so those
commercials pay for that [ __ ]
satellite genius it's like you're gonna
be a superhero man I guess that's a no
if I got a Nescafe campaign I'd be like
the [ __ ] a man like my god I don't
have to work that hard they do a couple
masks advance this [ __ ] dude is like
let's save some lives people he's being
Bruce my he's become the Bruce Wayne we
never got no [ __ ] like I've got this a
crazy fortune I could either I don't
know like open up some free private
schools I could work out some
infrastructure [ __ ] I could punch
criminals in the face he was right
though this is my Superman works alone
so because Affleck isn't coming back the
internet began to wonder who could be
the next Batman and hence the black
Batman penalty Michael B Jordan because
he's at the top of every list ain't
black Batman conversation that had was
had last week not to be confused with
the black bastards conversation which is
a completely different phone I mean like
this has been a dodgy beginning of Black
History Month that I mean look unless
it's totally up to you if you want to
how deep you want to go down the down in
the well but I just found it fascinating
that it's like that conversation never
had to happen at all and it just kept
going who's like you got 24 hours go to
sleep wake up you're gonna be on Good
Morning America and you've got to fix
some [ __ ] okay it's like I'm on it so as
I was saying here's what I did it's like
listen man if you're gonna do an
interview and I get that he thought the
idea of talking about desire thirst for
revenge would be appropriate to discuss
on this movie that's about revenge but
to not even for a second think that like
me
or like hey man maybe if you're gonna
talk about revenge leave out the race of
the guy that you went for revenge on
then it's just a story then you learn
some [ __ ] and then gone on with your
life sure I mean honestly like it's the
same [ __ ] story it really is and
nobody like he ain't dealing with
anything nope if he was just like I
wanted some bastards to come at me and
that's it but it's like she was she was
raped by a black man and and so I just
stood outside of borders for a week
waste hoping that any black man would
come and step to me and I could kill him
didn't it reminded me of remember the
extras episode where he like comes and
sits our Ricky Gervais and he's like I'd
like to do comedy I'm really funny yeah
I got aids from a prostitute just like
dead face serious like yeah yeah it was
it was a whole like 36 hours of really
Liam Neeson my you was my [ __ ] the there
was some I doubt it will go that far but
I mean no one one can never tell at this
point the there were some folks online
who were like hey man don't don't let
him be in men in black they wanted to
Chris Palmer I'm out or some well but
because he is a he's in it yes all over
the [ __ ] trailer white a bit I mean I
honestly I think that it's it's shitty
that he felt that way it should be that
he felt that the thing he did need to
apologize for was what seemed to be kind
of wanton racism of like or wanton
prejudice because there's to be very
careful about using racism v prejudice
because racism is systemic racism
requires power prejudice I didn't like
that person and I wanted to and I don't
know why right so yeah racism racism is
prejudice plus power
racism is oh I'm stopping you from
getting a mortgage in this place because
we don't like you oh I'm going to overly
police you or I'm going to affect your
life in a way that is independent of a
personal connection
it's it's systemic its governmental its
societal it's not I don't like that guy
I'm gonna kill that guy what is the clan
the clan is prejudiced like they don't
quite have power unless they're claiming
a small town right like it's a movie
that wouldn't even go to I'm sure
there's definitely historical small town
like Mississippi Burning version yes the
Klan stopping people from voting but so
wait so racism is systemic racism is is
larger than personal but you can benefit
from a racist system right but you and
me like I don't like you because you're
this that's prejudice big ism and and I
can't affect your life beyond the
physical proximity and violence so his
in this instance his was prejudice
prejudice yes he he prejudged every
black person based on his information
about one black person and so it's like
hey listen man that's like people 40
years ago can it's a different place a
different time and I get it but the fact
that he was like and the problem was
that vengeance is bad wait hold on
that's the more that's what you got from
that story you know and then online
people like well you have to account
that people can change and evolve over
time and maybe admit their mistakes as
they go yeah he totally can if you told
this to her yesterday told the story
yesterday and did not say I learned that
all black people are not worth murder I
just learned
maybe murders not cool oh my god I live
it feels like you have a little bit of
Truth and Reconciliation pressed or to
do well he was a good cop bad cop and
lego movie right mm-hmm
will segue using that to I just read
right before you got here
Lego - lego movie - the second part or
whatever came out not doing awesome
no it's doing pretty okay but not
awesome what is the I mean I saw it
did you I did I did I went to go see it
in in in 4dx thanks to our fellows Brett
Deacon and the gang oh my god give them
a plug no for the 40 acts as a way to
see a [ __ ] movie man really on a 40 X
theater near you they're usually in the
big cities I think there's new New York
Chicago Florida I think they have all
day open one down there yeah it's
[ __ ] amazing this would be an
enjoyable movie to see him 40x was it um
it what it was that the 40x of it all
was really cool but the movie itself is
not that it's bad it's just not nearly
as revelatory as the first one was I
mean just to imagine what you thought
you were gonna get walking into the lego
movie and then what you got
well ooh all right was it when I walked
into the lego movie insanely low
expectations mm-hmm and you know it
wasn't like oh my low expectations I was
surprised it was actually pretty
watchable I you know I went in going
like well I do want to see the Batman
thing looks kind of amusing right now
the handle Batman that walked out back
on these guys [ __ ] geniuses is one of
the greatest things the human hands have
ever [ __ ] made it's so beautiful yeah
and like the ending the last like 10
minutes of that first lego movie is
majestic yes it'll break your [ __ ]
heart if it wasn't already broken and it
only amplifies everything that you'd
seen before all the conflicts all of the
the drama is now made more trenchant
because it's a dad who doesn't want to
keep the play with his toys and one kid
who really wants to play with toys but
it means playing with his dad and all of
that [ __ ] just made everything feel so
much better in the second movie it's
like okay there's some of that a little
bit there is towards the tail end of it
a a a here's what's happening in the
real world and how that informed what
you just watched right but the jokes
aren't quite as funny the meta stuff
isn't quite as meta it's it's not it's
just not as surprising as the first one
was inevitably because it's the second
one right it's not bad at all like if
you if you had like a six year old who
dragged you to the movie like alright
this is pretty good but you would not
tell other adults
you should go [ __ ] and see that the way
we all did firstly the label is that
somebody described
it is like the difference between Toy
Story and Toy Story 2 a little bit where
they were like look I like Tori story
too but it wasn't like Holly [ __ ] yeah
it was like there's a girl and a horse
right that was the big ad and stuff yeah
it's like this second time you seen a
magic trick
what is like oh it's magic that's
supposed to what the [ __ ] was that
did that guy like legitimately divine
cuz I don't know how you do that right
huh you saw like a Batman movie I did
where is this if you had to raid all for
Le lego ninjago which I don't even know
it wasn't really a thing but if of the
lego movie lego movie 2 and Lego Batman
movie I think I think it's it's it's
Lego the first one by far
[Music]
I think it's Lego Batman it's a
beautiful movie it's beautiful and I
didn't I wasn't like over the moon about
Lego Batman but upon seeing it again so
I don't know this is doing a lot of
things really well it really really does
and Rosa Rosario oh yeah who's fantastic
she's great
yeah and Galifianakis is fun and then
Joker and this one is this one is three
huggin Will Arnett is like yeah I mean
that's why the game a movie I'll watch
it do that all day his Batman is [ __ ]
yeah fun but I mean it's beautiful and
it's gorgeous but you know there there
is no moment in this movie like [ __ ]
the Millennium Falcon showing up in the
lego movie right and oh my god today and
is that [ __ ] Harrison Ford's voice and
it's nothing quite that like holy [ __ ]
they did what they got that so yeah I
mean go if you saw the first one you
like the second I'm gonna definitely and
I'm sure I will but it's not it sounds
like Incredibles and Incredibles - yeah
like if you have to go to the theater to
see a Miller and Lord production goes
you spider-verse there's yet again yeah
anytime you do five in theater in the
theater because I didn't get a screening
because I'm not in the Academy when the
DGA might be soon the
what about the I read something online
where you were like the trick is to
bring somebody new each time yeah I
brought like three separate new people
which is like here's what we're doing
and I'm gonna watch you watch it it's
not gonna be weird at all I swear
did you like [ __ ] you lose I borrowed
my [ __ ] copy and he hasn't returned
it in a month
I [ __ ] love kill that guy
Gilligan he was a Liev Schreiber was
fantastic as the King pen and I loved
their rendering I loved the whole
[ __ ] thing I still love like you know
[ __ ] Chris Pine spider-man being like
you know wear masks you gotta hide your
identity
promise me to wear a mask everybody's
got everybody in this part you don't
know to trust like I think that whole
introduction of you know classic mmm-hmm
[ __ ] Winky spot yeah let's do this
one last time yeah I think that the
moment I fell in love with it was and
it's this tiny so [ __ ] throwaway joke
it's when they're escaping from alchemax
and it's like all right act casual
selecting a bagel and then he walks by
nobody takes a gun out and and miles is
running he swaps the computer for the
bagel and miles is going through the the
sliding doors and he throws the bagel up
in the air and it lands on the head of
another guy and the the the sound effect
is bagel know if like somebody [ __ ]
did that like somebody cared enough
they're like I'm gonna hand draw in the
world bagel and sound onomatopoeia yeah
funny and charming and [ __ ] it just
encapsulate sever ething good and
wonderful about comic books while
telling its own story that takes you on
an adventure like I legit enjoyed the
story and it's not a story they took
from someplace out the original [ __ ]
story
you know it's like watch and like
somebody took all your Star Wars figures
and played with them and showed you a
[ __ ] Star Wars storyline that you
were like oh my god this is [ __ ] you
can do this yeah I'll never how am I
supposed to have a [ __ ] play with
anybody else
and know how to play with those [ __ ]
toys okay so instead of talking about 40
men who will be the new Batman I've
heard a rumor hmm did you hear this no
no Rob Pattinson I I heard that as well
has it been debunked yeah it has never
been verified or sourced very well and
just like I have heard a rumor toilet
guy and then nobody's like I've
confirmed that rumor it's just a rumor
i am i i when i heard that i wasn't like
now so I don't know like I'm I could see
him pulling it off I guess I mean it
especially if you're doing wash Batman
not like [ __ ] I mean think about it
Norrish Batman means more human Batman
because the last version of Batman they
put up there his suit was so [ __ ]
ridiculously big like you know it just
well it looks like action figure about
it yeah so or this gives you a chance to
like Michael Keaton it more mm-hmm put
like a cool actor and also result like
Rob Pattinson can't get [ __ ] real
buff right he put on some whoever it is
I'm sure going to fill out the suit but
I think you know like he's a good actor
to us the thing we left I mean [ __ ]
he is hold off that Edward [ __ ] there
was the effort okay right but I I mean
that man is a star of your movie and
like do you need to have an actor in
there who is a bigger name than Batman
well probably not like finally like sure
armie hammer would be great sure there's
a handful of other like very handsome
sort of Lego late 20s early 30s dudes
who could pull it off but what if
there's somebody we've never seen before
who's just amazing and like doesn't
carry any the baggage of [ __ ] sparkly
vampires or any of that check out the
Kathy Bates of Batman yeah it's like
Kathy Bates Springs on to most people's
radars with like misery
yeah like be the casting director who
finds Peter O'Toole for Lawrence of
Arabia like that was that [ __ ]
first movie it's like you know what
who's that for Batman who's that kid
who's like a bricklayer now working
somewhere is tough as balls and can
act that would make [ __ ] Affleck
albert finney
it would fill out great Blake greater
just passed away Albert Finney who keep
it on brand was in wolf and might be
Skyfall he played James model their
housekeeper supposed to be Sean Connery
that was supposed to be the plan was
Sean Connery Skyfall was going to be the
house of retired double O's but Sean
Connery don't tell me that yeah so he
passed on it and I think it's because he
was ill right but that was the original
idea was that he would be James Bond
this is where James Bond's go to die
that would have been so metal yeah they
couldn't have pulled that off why did
they they couldn't call Roger Morgan
come on give us another one George
Lazenby like come on Albert Finney did a
great job Albert Finney was an amazing
actor Daddy Warbucks that's a little on
Brandy's well look here remember that
movie yeah and ran it on cable like
crazy when we first got cable in Jersey
and [ __ ] we got four movies buddies yeah
watch looker and the looker gun was such
a cool concept like this flash and
[ __ ] freeze and [ __ ] you can go
do whatever [ __ ] steal their nut or
whatever the [ __ ]
so yeah mapped but without the kitty
teen porn or kind of like the girl the
gold watch and everything which was a
movie that runs on imagination WPIX
syndicated yeah so Peter O'Toole winds
up getting that [ __ ] role in that
movie in the launch of Arabian because
all we're finding is like I ain't gonna
do that
listen too hot too much [ __ ] desert
oh my god sand
I don't mind any when two so far sand
gets everywhere he for the real-life
[ __ ] Anakin Skywalker
[ __ ] how did we get there
oh that mr. Peter O'Toole find me find
me a new shiny thing you're looking for
our [ __ ] make a star yeah I mean we
deserve to be star can it be like oh he
was like the third lead on a [ __ ] CBS
procedural then I mean it [ __ ] I am
sure Stephen Amell right now is calling
all of his agents being like hey you
need that you need Batman right ahead
they're like seven years experience of
grunting in a mask over there
I can't imagine like those movie people
seem to really distance themselves from
the they really did TV people and stuff
not that he couldn't do it I mean lord
knows he knows how to put on a mask and
growl and that's what Batman required
little failed this city
yeah but uh I I wonder find some shiny
new Pearlie do the thing that we can do
with actresses very well which is like
hey here is a young actress who you've
never seen before but she's got talent
she's [ __ ] Jennifer Lawrence who some
tiny indie that that somehow got her
nominated for an Oscar and then she's a
[ __ ] movie star or that actress Kiki
was an if Beale Street could talk to you
see mm-hmm he's [ __ ] amazing man and
she's so good that only can you just
narrate the whole [ __ ] thing - it's a
thankless [ __ ] job and she pulled it
off yeah like there's there's a depth of
talent that I'm sure is out there
somewhere untapped that you could find
the perfect Bruce Wayne it's nice to
know there's a Batman movie in our
future and it's gonna be a different
flavor but there's we've known this for
a [ __ ] year now yeah like and when
they I saw that news was all over
Twitter like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and guess
what Matt Reeves is talking about me
there's gonna be new Irish and like I
knew that duh you better need deep
better say something new no I was like
oh yeah and even though I guess like but
even that I was like I knew that
confirming a thing we knew was gonna be
true I don't know like I'm sure I'm sure
he knows what he's doing he's like look
I got years before this movie's gonna
happen and I don't even know if I'm ever
gonna get to [ __ ] do him I keep my
mouth shut until it's time and Duchenne
nobody not everyone operates like me
where it's like oh I'm gonna talk about
things three years before we knew but
yeah I'm look I'm in shows called fat
man beyond crisis exactly
we'll be a show used to be called fat
man I'm Batman once about the time so
I'm all I'm all their sound and what
he's doing sounds interesting I'm just
saying it's not an interesting year ago
you said you know what isn't you though
but they are they are spinning off
Aquaman yeah
internally called the trench and so
they're doing it like where's Aquaman
was what 200 million or something like
that this is like a 50 million dollar
kind of see oriented horror movie using
those trench characters right smart yeah
I mean I think James won those like
archers are new they don't go deep in
the DC bench they're only from like 2011
yeah Geoff Johns creations are indeed
indeed but yeah I think there's no Jason
Momoa in this it is not gonna have
Aquaman it's not gonna have mera mera
mera whatever James Wan will probably
not direct but he will produce here
before all said and done kids you may
see an Aquaman or a mirror appearance
you might I'm sure they'll be you know
just hey listen Jason all we need you do
is come in and say mommy and then just
walk on out we're probably look it's
even cheaper to [ __ ] get a black man
to appearance you don't even need an
actor look here's the [ __ ] suit it's
not even a suit
here's the digital asset you know one
[ __ ] cameo by him I'm like aha [ __ ]
that's how you get me man get me show
him in the trailer I'm like he's in it
oh man just going deep but let's be
honest I'm going anyway um man that's
good for them that's smart
yeah totally like something because like
we said you're going yeah Aquaman [ __ ]
cuz we love comics there's a bunch of
people out there from him they're like
oh he was in the comic books like they
just saw a fantastic underwater Star
Wars movie and [ __ ] so if you can give
him a little more and [ __ ] like from
that sequence they'll go for it yeah and
I think it also will help sort of sate
the hunger for Aquaman material because
there's no sign on when Aquaman 2 is
going to happen I mean clearly they'll
do it it's going to happen but there
have been no serious talks at the studio
about even locking down one
and making the New Deal for the second
one and whatever they have to do to get
Momoa look I'm not sure how many movies
he signed for whether or not the tiny
cameo on BBS and then Justice League and
then this fulfills whatever obligation
he had who knows I can't imagine I got
to imagine Aquaman is the first of three
probably we're getting more DC Comics
movies that are off the beaten path
mm-hmm not Superman not Batman but now
here's the trench
it's like their version of like
guardians the galaxy when you first
heard like what Marvel's doing guardians
like why would they [ __ ] do that
that's a mistake and this at least is
tested IV we've seen it work in a
[ __ ] movie that made a billion
dollars so if they spend less on it and
it makes two hundred million and they
spend fifty that's it that's an
excellent business they still created
there they've fucking's they've created
their Laverne and Shirley
yes they yes they did what else we got
elsewhere in comic book to screen news
why the last man you know it never
happens that bar is me getting really
[ __ ] baked no there's not nearly as
much coughing why the last man why last
man because mark the they're turning it
into something you're turning into a TV
show on FX [ __ ] took a minute right
it really did especially for something
that is as beloved as this ya know it's
been it's been swirling around the
development pool
Brian cave on Brian cave on PA teairra
here we go Pia Guerra
di Guerra yeah it's been an is but over
ten years old at this point yeah James I
mean God that the book was launched in
2002 so it is almost twenty years old
Jesus
where's time go people love this [ __ ]
book they really do and I did and you
did I did I loved it too dad
you read the whole thing I read the
whole thing beginning - yep finish well
I don't remember what happened
I remember being satisfied by it though
um but do you see it's got serious
potential all over it oh yeah oh yeah
it's good is this something they wanted
to do as a movie at one point when
somebody came to their senses yes it has
let's see but the bone pedigree it does
new line acquired the film rights in
2007 that's [ __ ] 12 years ago bright
k bomb was like 12 years later oh yeah
David David Boyer
Carl's Ellsworth and directed DJ Caruso
he's dead GG Caruso is doing xxx and
then in March 2012
Mathew Federman and Steven Scala who did
TV Jericho we're in final negotiations
to take on the property with producer JC
[ __ ] Chris bender and gore again
producing bender spanked bender spanked
that fell apart in September 2014 when
Vaughan said that the rights were in the
process reverting back to him and the
movie is dead and then FX got into the
picture and let me see 2014 it took five
years yeah I'm sorry they put it in 2015
it took like four years yeah why um I
mean I'm see creative teams like coming
up with a take they like creative teams
and I think that the Michael Green our
boy Michael oh yeah he did Logan and
murder only were in express and Neil's
show American guys and
Bladerunner 2049 is working like a song
we're gonna like it son of a [ __ ] but
he's been working on this for like three
years and and he even said that in 2017
his take on it just changed drastically
after Trump got elected president he
said he had to put the script down for a
couple months and reassess reassess it
tonally because it became a different
creature became a violent protest it
couldn't not be political and had to
embrace him had to find a way in and I
had to find a way to channel my own
dismayed there's permanent rage into it
while keeping in Ottawa oh yes so he is
running it along with Aida Kroll who was
on Luke Cage with Jo Coker where's Bryan
keep on him this involved in now I think
he's involved but I think he's also
taking a bit of a step back from active
development I think he'll be an
executive producer but I think he's
right in the room I don't think I think
he'll read scripts and stuff but he's
not I thought it was very cool that the
writer of deadly class was also the
writer of the show does the class yeah I
mean I think it it depends on I mean
Brian Vaughn has been through the
wringer as far as TV goes like he was on
lost first season and I don't think
loved it he was on he developed and ran
the first year of under the dome from
the Stephen King thing that was supposed
to Showtime I went to CBS and they've
got I think just first season was huge
and then let's just vanished because it
was are we still under the dome is there
a new dome how do we keep doming this
dome and he walked away kind of
disgusted I think with TV and so
Runaways which was is another comic book
that he wrote yeah he's just an
executive consultant on that on that
holy show wonderful show
it really is it's really strong oh so
yeah I think he's he's he's involved in
it but he does not fingers on the tiller
right
nobody fingers those kids yeah it's
alright well good for him it sounds like
I mean look it's getting made and that's
a good thing but it's a team wonderful
hands it really is there
and let me see and that's for who FX
that is for FX and let's see
they had great success with with Legion
great [ __ ] [ __ ] with Lukas latest
success with Legion which I read this
week Legion is bringing the character of
Professor X on to their final season
yeah so they'll be casting a professor
actually got any ideas I mean I'm
telling you I it might not work for TV
because he's a little bit too big of a
star for somebody who asked me like but
there was a little news story that that
at some point Maher without Alford Keanu
Reeves role in the MCU to be I think the
Jude Law character and Captain Marvel uh
uh and he turned it down
yeah but wait why because to be fair I
think he's [ __ ] Keanu Reeves and was
like I want to have like I want to be
part of this I'm gonna be part of the
fabric of it like I want to by the time
I wanted to be Batman and [ __ ] if I'm
if what we're reading is correct the
rumors do you love playing Marvel man
like you're part of it but that more I
guess but if I had time I mean to tell
me he's holding on for a better part
yeah but yeah my my theory was he could
be a good professor it could be a great
professor yeah he's kind of now that you
said it's like shaven bald and then
there's been a movie I think we saw
about Heather Jackie stop we're talking
about Keanu little bigger was that
that's true
yeah no he got to keep Sarah no but it
may be something the make or the matrix
yeah my head shaved there you go yeah
put him and put him in the chair and
yeah totally whoa me into crazy man
remember him in matrix when at the end
when the [ __ ] music soaring and he
realizes who he is bullets are coming he
just goes no they stop and drop by
father so Ken that movie [ __ ] one of
the greatest comic book movies ever made
not a stunt a single going I know I
remember
who said that Clark Craig said that to
Laurence Fishburne at the at the Stanley
memorial thing so I love comic movies
and to be sitting next to it [ __ ]
Mark Hamill and Morpheus and it was like
yeah I was in the biggest comic book
movie that was never based on a comic
book Chucky
giving up to my [ __ ] neighbor
Laurence Fishburne he lives nearby he
does he very nearby letter a never seen
him once
jumping goes like the wind like you
never seen him I know where he lives but
I've never seen him my kid though saw
him on the day of the Stan Lee memorial
she was driving home and he was welcome
to hell cuz again he like lives in the
neighborhood you know she was like we
saw Laurence Fishburne's burger on home
I was like what'd he mean so I'm she's
like he was walking I was like you stop
and pick him up know where he's going he
lives like right nearby I think is he
out for a walk or is he like in need of
assistance I think he well cuz he lived
through the walk from Chinese like like
I could walk to the Chinese Theatre in
pretty decent time well you know I
wouldn't because I'm a adult and I have
a car he might have gone jobbed off or
maybe walked out maybe he's healthy and
[ __ ] like that he's like I'm gonna take
a healthy constitutional that I mean
there's one thing to be like walking for
pleasure and everything to like walk to
a destination because that's the weird
thing
yeah he did you you were there it was
there yeah when I [ __ ] like like he
totally took me out of the game when at
one point cuz I was like you but your
interaction with comics and he talked
about like you know before I went off to
make Apocalypse Now my [ __ ] brain
cave just like you go deep man God
you've just always been there you're
Nicholson in the shining like you've
always been here Jack like [ __ ] I forgot
and he was talking about like he was
it was a teenager who's still reading
comics yeah he said he was like I didn't
have the money because the price went up
from like 25 cents to 35 cents above it
I had to stop buying comics and then I
went off to make vitamins now then I had
money about comics again
it was and he also made the like whose
dick that I got a sock joke to be
tomorrow but I got to be Goliath um yeah
he was [ __ ] magic yeah that was cool
that was a really cool event we got I
guess the matrix that's okay yeah oh and
he should play Professor X I don't like
bad greens TV show which is why the
Legion is bringing Professor X in Legion
is also on FX FX that's how we got that
we're talking about [ __ ] why yes this
is like today though they're willing to
take chances on count book sure they are
laughter senator ones yeah I don't think
when I get straight down the middle
superhero thing no like Legion is rocky
yeah and not why you like stupid but
just it's a unique its conceptual it's
you know let's let's show you what it is
like to be inside a mentally ill mind
masquerading as a superhero show this is
very trippy this could be this this
sounds like this is the [ __ ] perfect
milieu it really does it really does
I I'm excited for it Diane Lane is
playing the President of the United
States
[ __ ] yeah Barry Keegan is York
Ellen aim Ellen aim in the attackers the
rockers I thought it was this idiot I
can see attack it I have a t-shirt she
plays the president and who Barry Barry
Keegan plays Yorick
he was in killing him sacred ear and yep
magic in that movie a movie so [ __ ]
disturbing and he's so he's the lead
last man be the last man Wow
what an age of wonder we live in man
making everything there making
everything and this one I thought like
it does feel late he does not like to
late like oh that [ __ ] their moment
was over but you would have thought with
as much claim as this [ __ ] had
this would have been made 10 years ago
but look it's get made at the right time
yeah gonna be at the right place they're
gonna treat it well especially like to
talk about what the last man would be
like in a world full of women in our
current time of like toxic masculinity
and me too and all that [ __ ] like it
does feel lying around the balls days
right
yeah like however long it took it took
the right amount of time drew this
speaking of everything is getting a shot
in the Sun whether it needs to or not
escape from New York is giving another
round on the remake train yeah we talked
about the Sun Babel villain
yeah no Carpenter though I think he's
going to be an executive producer but I
don't think that that's just his name
Islamic yeah it doesn't sound like it's
gonna be like on the recent Halloween he
seems to play a role right I mean did
the score but like it seemed like he was
involved in some I think he was this one
and Big Trouble in Little China I
remember he talked about like nobody's
called me mm-hmm
so this one same thing yeah I understand
I killed he'll probably get to read a
script
he'll probably will definitely get paid
but I don't know how much meaningful
participation he'll have so far yeah but
Leigh Whannell who did the Saw movies
and most recently upgrade no I've
created that action movie where the
dudes like yeah we it's like [ __ ]
robot aside yeah
machine he's director he's writing
there's no current deal for him to
direct but it's a possibility
upgrade is what got him the job
ultimately right and if the script turns
out well so nothing I can make a movie
I'm sure it let me make a movie uh new
Snake Plissken
yeah yeah I'm afraid yeah I'm a I feel
like Kurt Russell got a lot of gas and
tank left still people like to dude like
just have that Netflix and a [ __ ]
thing seems like an odd argument snake
plugs well I was just Santa he just
played Santa like why not [ __ ] like
hide it to me
Vaman charge I'm like in this nostalgia
crazy age
why the [ __ ] would we have another Snake
Plissken the [ __ ] is still alive
fairly like [ __ ] healthy and he's in
movies all the time like it's not even
like dig him out of mothballs know who's
seen Kurt Russell in a few years he's
always working drank and it's not even
like he's Mel Gibson like he's toxic and
yeah well they like this [ __ ] guy I
can't find anybody has got bad word to
say about he's been in the business 50
[ __ ] years and there was always the
talk that it was escape from New York
and then escape from LA and then and
then escape from Earth was gonna be the
third one they shouldn't me yeah
there was always carpenters idea for how
this would evolve was the last one is
earth is [ __ ] it had been turned into
a an EMP wasteland and there's no power
and there's no light there's no nothing
the last place for you to go is to get
off the [ __ ] planet make that [ __ ]
make that [ __ ] move mr. Russell you
know make sure rum making so much money
somebody will rent a studio we'd make
billions
we'd make people happy that's for sure
yeah man oh man so I look I'm sure I'll
see the this version but I don't know I
think there's a little more gas in the
tank I think you go to your real guy I
think you're gonna make a lot of money
with your real guy like even if people
like I understand like there's a whole
generation didn't grow up with this
[ __ ] movie don't give a [ __ ] about it
but people get caught up in a fervor and
frenzy and just like he'd [ __ ] it's
like a virus gets passed along and you
know if everybody's like hey this is
something
got to do [ __ ] people jump in even if
they're like what is this now escape
from what snake ooh I don't know I'm
just going like I roll the dice on Kurt
yeah I mean I I see the other version of
it only because Mad Max fury road worked
so well it's like a we're gonna recast
Mad Max yeah yeah yeah you know like
we're gonna totally new guy and it's
gonna be it's George Miller doing
[ __ ] genius level work and but that's
the other thing is like it ain't
somebody takin carpenter and doing
carpenter Miller did Miller right he
just had to get a new Mad Max yeah well
like so I see that version of it but
there's also they like just [ __ ] let's
one last time guys let's LA didn't work
out so well for us in New York is a
classic I think we could we could bring
this one home that sounds like a [ __ ]
good movie man escape from Earth and
[ __ ] take it to space alright so it's
happening we can't stop it maybe we'll
be happy it happened when it's over and
stuff I ain't against it I'm against
anything I'm stoned they could tell me I
mean look over at [ __ ] on arrow
they're doing like a bastardized version
of onomatopoeia my character I'm not
like I'm like go for it
life is long like maybe I'll get to do
my version one day like you know how
many Batman's there been like this is
the first permutation of Green Arrow
there'll be others I'm surprised they
haven't taken a swing at Green Arrow
movie oh man give it a second but like
you know all this [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
that they're doing especially with like
your Warner Brothers right mm-hmm
Warner Brothers owns new line so Warner
Brothers responsible for those Rings
movies mm-hmm in those Rings movies you
got that Lego lash - twice so you
already you already had the jump on
everybody like oh [ __ ] look at his arrow
nonsense and people go
for this and [ __ ] it wouldn't have been
that much more you know to be like well
let's take Legolas put him in a movie
set in the present like call it Green
Arrow like it's just a dude CG you don't
really fire arrows although I watched
behind the scenes on the recent Robin
Hood movie mm-hmm with what's his [ __ ]
Aaron Edgerton he learned to fire
[ __ ] arrows where the
behind-the-scenes footage was nuts dude
watching this [ __ ] shoot three
arrows like who put poop in and within
like five seconds wow this is like
you're like oh there could be a green
arrow he'd be shot by before you got the
second arrow off but like you could go
out there in the world and [ __ ] do
that there's a video I saw on I can't
even have I got a link to this [ __ ]
thing don't do it I'm not just a good
saying it's it's more plausible than any
other [ __ ] superhero I think against
working Batman he's just got a bow and
arrow
he's less Batman like Batman requires
you to [ __ ] look ridiculous Green
Arrow well to be fair he doesn't have
the feather in his jaunty hat
it's what a green [ __ ] letter and a
bombing outfit is like look at me I'm
good ears are you a bunny no my back are
eukaryotes like a bunny video this old
dude who had been a Archer for his
entire life and his physique had evolved
over time because all he would ever do
is hold one hand this way and pull with
the other with his right hand and his
entire back was it was like they're
[ __ ] Hunchback in 300 like just
muscles on one side that were
overdeveloped and muscles on the other
side they were like long and lean and he
was just this weird misshapen guy what
could do that [ __ ] thing was just
knocking down [ __ ] melons a hundred
yards away yeah that's what they were
having this kid dude yeah like hit these
targets with arrows little bags tied to
him or something like that I was not so
it was like somebody could do this [ __ ]
because on arrow
he just pretends hmm like there ain't no
[ __ ] the but there's a bowl but I got
a string and there are no arrows they
just throw those in and those arrows are
[ __ ] cheap son when it comes to
visual effects budgets and snuff because
like when we work on flash or Supergirl
you go through the budgets of the biz
effects and you try to bring it down and
be like we don't need this we don't need
this but like there's one like the Zoop
in and out is like 15 or bucks those
except the cheapest like effect and
they're like no the arrows on arrow or
the cheapest and I was like really
they're like so much so that they'll
farm it out to another house they can
just do that in the house well it's
exactly like that even honestly less per
annum mm-hmm you might get away with it
for like a hundred bucks like all in
Pereiro Wow and and the way they talked
about it might even be less than a
hundred but around considering the show
is called arrow yeah that's visual
visual effects they should do some like
[ __ ] kids parties with that [ __ ] like
imagine if you could have your kid be
arrow at a party and you just have the
video tape to prove it
I'm listening guys we made a thousand
dollars putting arrows in this [ __ ]
kid's birthday party video as a junior
so what you're saying is like you know
it's like you can bring your clown if
you want but you can hire our company we
come in we costume your kid we throw a
little green screen behind I mean [ __ ]
we invite everybody in the party to act
in this [ __ ] movie you feel this
party yeah and then have a like foot
foot foot foot and like we will get it
back to you within 48 hours and it'll be
like you know it's not gonna look like
[ __ ] it's gonna be cinema ready but
it'll be pretty [ __ ] convincing and
more importantly we're gonna put the
arrows in it's like when you go to
[ __ ] like Universal Studios and you
get to like hop on Harry Potter's
[ __ ] broom and suddenly the green
screens behind you mean like oh I'm
chasing after Dementors mummy so you in
the Batpod like sliding through the
autumn city you know if we ever want to
do another horror movie I was doing
these dopey horror movies in Canada but
a really unsettling one would be you as
a killer with a British boys
[Laughter]
he's a creepy way do you have any toffee
No step step step
did you ever go to Universal when was
the first time you went to Universal
Studios - you a grown-ass man no I was a
kid it was here as a kid do you remember
when they do like that screen test show
where it's just like you know we'll pick
three people from the audience now
you're in this plane and there was no I
never did that [ __ ] then like then you
and you we're gonna cast you as the
Blues Brothers and they put [ __ ]
jackets and hats and glasses I mean and
then you buy a video at the end of the
[ __ ] thing like that shows the whole
thing together and stuff it sounds not
too dissimilar from that thing I think
was a Warner it was a Warner Brothers
Studio Tour that's what it was so you
can be you could hop on a broom and be
Harry Potter you could get behind the
Batpod and be Batman was the other one
and you do that on the tour yeah and
they give you a video yep especially
like 100 bucks at the end of the day
they get some [ __ ] like look it's me
and the Cape is flying and you're
swooping through this is the same
principle except now it's high-tech and
way better I'm sure yep
Wow yeah get much quick with marketing
kids no [ __ ] ideas you're stealing
kids give him away what are the news we
go World War Z remember that movie right
I remember the very successful book and
I remember the equally successful if not
more successful movie that had nothing
to do with the book of event sharing a
title correct but coming back it was
going to David Fincher was going to be
directing the sequel to World War Z are
you what yes he was until he's not
anymore now I was just I was it's weird
you shocked me and then you took my
shock away cause I'm like well it's not
happening but really yeah yeah what cuz
he's friends with Brad Pitt or something
yeah I mean Fight Club let's see how did
this happen if they work together beyond
Fight Club it must ever sound who am i
[ __ ] thing
seven Fight Club
yeah the development is the latest
obstacle for the sequel which was put
into motion soon after the emission
movie came out and grossed 540 million
worldwide
that same year which was 2013 je Bayona
came on board as director who did ok
monster college a big Bayona JJ hey vay
Johnny J Bay Jana he ain't no Bona she's
kid I'm on the phone he came on in 2013
to direct and in 2015 paramount
announced a release date by 2016 Bona
was gone and a nearly year-long on on on
again and off again and go she ate with
Fincher began he signed on to February
2017 oh wait they also did the Curious
Case of Benjamin Button together that's
it that's the other one yeah they
[ __ ] Reedy aged Brad Pitt right it
was on its way to a spring or early
summer production start in Atlanta but
paramount said that budgetary issues
came to a head and it's unclear how long
those issues had been brewing and they
halted pre-production on the movie which
is a shame because David Fincher doing
the [ __ ] zombies would have been
amazing would have been a hot man I
would [ __ ] watch that but why now
because they don't say yeah they just
said that apparently sources say that it
was gonna cost too much [ __ ] money so
that's dead or at least sleeping for a
while
what is he been up to Fincher yeah he
was gonna make a 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea movie for a long time he'd been
developing that for Fox but I think
that's on hold while Fox decides if
they're gonna have a future under Disney
um wait a second
he was gonna do it 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea mother yeah yeah I think he
seems like he's like just wants to
indulge his [ __ ] nerd at this point
zombies underwater [ __ ] no I had a nerd
I thought it was all classy and I mean
he made an alien 3 yeah I guess you're
right he started out in [ __ ] nerd
countries
um the last thing he did was it's there
you know named [ __ ] remember Ellen
through I'll never forgive that mother
killing off nuke off-screen oh my god I
was so invested in that little girl she
the whole movie was about Ripley saving
that little [ __ ] girl and you opened
the movie by killing that little girl
mm-hmm you're so lucky Fight Club was so
good erased seven sin seven was amazing
everything else everything out even
alien 3 is a [ __ ] type movie but the
man and kill off Hicks yellow kill Hicks
all you want but kill off kill L kill
every pill [ __ ] it Ripley keep the kid I
got to meet her in real life the actress
who carry Jerry and Jerry and Wow she's
she's that kid is so awesome remember I
mean she's an adult she has that kid but
Mike he's one of those meeting people
where I'm like man like I gotta tell you
my whole [ __ ] life
I thought you were [ __ ] awesome five
greatest child performances ever put on
[ __ ] film you're up there with
Shirley Temple [ __ ] now you've
got to carriage my little blonde girl to
a low-budget split and that led to glass
how many voices can you do a saw James
McAvoy didn't see glass
I will I saw him he was hosting SNL mmm
talented very good like crazy funny and
can do many voices and like just you got
it like you really got it they should be
Batman got back that play I was gonna
say you should play Professor X in that
TV she already shaved my head once of a
[ __ ] you still got one more in the
[ __ ] chamber right Dark Phoenix word
has not been positive
the things I've read I read I read some
not awesome things things I've seen and
they've made an impression on me yeah
they've been having screenings test
screenings and apparently
yeah they got trouble right there in
River City capital T rhymes with B and
that stands for Phoenix yeah yeah man
it's it sounds like the final go-around
for your classic Fox X characters yeah
may not be a wonderful swan song would
have wished for a slightly more tram
vent ride off into the [ __ ] sunset
but ironically like it's about the
Phoenix excuse me rising from the ashes
but this is it they've already started
talking about Disney finally made
mention of Wolverine in a story I read
were they're like yeah we'll be looking
for a new woven younger Wolverine
so I'm happened but it's like them going
oh yeah we're Disney will be making
Wolverine yeah don't think that's never
going to happen we you will be able to
buy a pair of [ __ ] claws at every
Disney Store and all across the [ __ ]
spectrum like that's Dan and Wolverine
you know who we've only known in this
lifetime is to be Hugh Jackman we'll be
James Bond and Batman so many people are
gonna play that character yeah like we
didn't we didn't buy Fox to not do more
Wolverine stories like that's the only
reason we bought Deadpool which we can't
technically owned up to owning we're
gonna let that [ __ ] keep going on over
at Fox yeah we bought the x-men and then
we bought The Simpsons and everything
else is collateral that's true I forgot
about the Simpsons
when's that kick in I mean immediately I
guess weird man do you think they'll do
anything with it I mean if I'm them just
gonna just let it keep doing what it's
doing like let it like maybe they'll
make another movie which they've let sit
for a while but that shows another one
anyway I could totally make a movie you
know and that other the Simpson movie
was pretty
made a lot of money to get like just
very well it was shocking that they
actually didn't [ __ ] go again man
maybe they were just like local count
our blessings we got that well he had
spider pig inspired and that was the one
that showed Bart's dick remember the
ride frame when the French fry gets
beloved yeah thanks for hanging out Liz
de and I can't wait to get done with the
movie while I'm gonna enjoy the [ __ ] out
of making the movie but when I'm done I
get to come back home and then we shall
resume fat man but hopefully Marc come
down down Louisiana way I mean even if
we don't show do a show I might come
down coming down cuz I come down you're
gonna be in the [ __ ] movie because I
[ __ ] love Louisiana and I've never
been in a movie so both of these things
sound like it's bang I win it's good for
the brand to a really shitty British
accent what's your friend bring to this
might you have a a man rock a British
accent this creepy man [ __ ] you heard
about some creative people and then you
listen to some people get creative and
shed so far off flung off track Batman
I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith and for a fat
man beyond just stuck in the past
tune in next time same fat time say in
fact gentle smart guess back time or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
you